Omar al-bashir is 75 he ruled Sudan for
three decades but today the former
dictator sat silently in a cage in a
Khartoum court to be told that he was
guilty of money laundering and
corruption he was charged after
suitcases containing millions of dollars
were discovered at his home earlier this
year the defendant Omar Hassan armored
al Bashir is sentenced to detention in a
reformed facility for a period of two
years his sentence was light it was
thought that he might get 10 years and
because of his age he won't go to a
normal prison where supporters protested
inside and outside the court
shouting in his defence Bashir became
president after a coup in 1989 he was
brutal thousands were killed under his
rule and opponents were jailed he was
finally removed from power earlier this
year when the military stepped in after
nationwide demonstrations
al-bashir is wanted by the International
Criminal Court in The Hague for war
crimes he's accused of genocide in the
state of Darfur the UN estimates 300,000
people were killed during the conflict
there but the joint civil-military
government that now rules Sudan has said
that he will not be extradited and
instead will remain in the country to
face judgment the people who've joined
the transitional government and want
them held to account for his part in the
killings of demonstrators in April April
this year before he was overthrown the
elements of the transitional military
government who are from the former
military regime would be very reluctant
to send one of their own two to the
Hague because the events in Darfur and
the sort of crimes that took place there
it would extend far beyond President
Bashir there is more to come
al Bashir faces outstanding trials in
Sudan which will get underway in the
coming months he will be back in court
and he will almost certainly face longer
in prison but after 30 years ruling
through violence that will still not be
justice enough for many sudanese
alistair bunk all Sky News